telling us about this students and
leaders project thanks
it is about four minutes after the hour
and at our desk is a man
it's been really interesting to try to
pronounce his name i've known i've had a
harder name is it brady is that righty
that's exactly correct dan bryant what
kind of name is it it's an irish name
daniel patrick briety and there's the
book on the screen it's called the iron
triangle inside the secret world of the
carlyle group
what's it about
well it's about a company called the
carlyle group which folks here in
washington dc are pretty familiar with
carlyle group is
a private equity firm
and what that means is essentially they
buy and sell companies much like a
mutual fund buys and sells stocks
but the carlisle group is is very unique
in that
the way that they do their business is
that they hire
a number of very high profile
ex-politicians
folks like george bush senior
john major the former prime minister of
the uk
uh james baker the third um frank
carlucci the former secretary of defense
um so
there's a there's a long list of
ex-politicians and these guys are able
to help carlyle work the
government-regulated industries
such as defense and aerospace
telecommunications healthcare
because of their expertise in working in
these areas while they were public
servants
in the pr copy that sent out
a riveting history and a hard-hitting
expose the iron triangle clearly and
chillingly demonstrates how the carlisle
group is shaping u.s policy and reaping
astounding riches by insinuating itself
into the very fabric of the world's
economic structure
i do though want to read this to you and
get your to expound on it
watching and here's the book and we'll
show the audience watching
uh watch dogs might as well be barking
at the moon because the scandal here is
not what's illegal but what's legal has
this company the carlisle group named
after the hotel in new york city ever
done anything illegal well i i couldn't
say that they've never done anything
illegal i certainly never covered
uncovered anything that they did that
was illegal
and like like the book says like this is
an area of
business of politics that is relatively
unregulated
it's something that
the this confluence of politics and
business
where
it's it's referred to commonly as the
revolving door where a politician
serves for a time
in the white house or in other other
capacities
and then
leaves the white house and is able to
capitalize on
the knowledge that they gain there or
sometimes the actual policies that they
said and the legislation that they set
while they were in office
and then maybe returns
to to the white house during another
administration
this is something that's entirely legal
and in in many ways
i
endorse it because i believe that our
public servants should be able to
matriculate back into the ordinary
citizenry and and uh and and and pursue
their financial interests um just like
any other citizen
but in this case there have been some
some very disturbing conflicts of
interest that i think need to be further
investigated again from your pr sheet
how the former president bush george
herbert walker bush has repeatedly
advised his son on policy decisions
directly tied to carl isle investments
including reopening negotiations with
north korea to protect the more than one
billion carlyle has invested in korea's
struggling economy is that north korea's
struggling economy or south korea's
struggling economy well this was this
was in south korea's struggling economy
and this was a few years back um so
what what was happening at that time and
this is this is probably the most
disconcerting case um of a conflict of
interest that we've seen with the
carlyle group um as we know george
bussiner
is on the payroll at carlisle um and he
as we also know he routinely advises his
son on foreign policy decisions we've
seen in several cases him uh make calls
to foreign leaders on behalf of his son
especially during the beginning of this
administration
so
the conflict of interest arises when you
think about
george bersiner led a very successful
entry into the south korean market for
carlisle
he met with business leaders he met with
political leaders over there he did a
tour
of the country and ended up opening up
the doors for a very large
investment into south korea
in their telecommunications
infrastructure and also
into some of their healthy banks there
was only actually one healthy bank
remaining at the time
which is a bank called core am
so
when when george business then starts
advising his son on how to deal with
policy on the korean peninsula uh and in
particular towards north korea which has
been somewhat of a flip flop for this
administration they've gone back and
forth on north korea
obviously a lot has changed since uh
since 2001
but when george business comes in and
starts advising his son on how to deal
with uh north korea and the korean
peninsula it's a pretty clear conflict
of interest because of his financial
interest in the area and that's
something that and there's a reason that
this country is uh is
is loath to uh deal with conflicts of
interest for those who agree with the
president those lines by the way are
wide open right now so uh you can see it
there five eight five three eight zero
no one's calling on that line the other
lines who disagree the president are
full and may say something about their
interest in your book uh do you find
people who do not like the president
don't like your book
or do like your book do you like the
book um i do find that it has a much
stronger following certainly
among the liberal left um and i didn't
want the book to be politicized but i
suppose that that was inevitable
it is is clearly a book that is critical
of the bush administration um and of the
carlyle group and i think that uh it's
it's natural for folks who are critical
of the president to associate with it
our guest lives where in connecticut
bridgewater connecticut very small
farming town first child on the way in
june a graduate of boston college in
1993 in english and philosophy have you
ever worked for a political candidate i
have not let's go to miami florida
you're on the air oh yes good morning mr
breody i have a question for you sure i
haven't read your book but i'm looking
forward to reading it some time after
the first gulf war george bush the elder
took his entire family to kuwait
including laura bush wife of the current
um george bush the lesser
do you have any idea what he got from
the government of kuwait what he brought
back why has nothing been turned into
the u.s treasury what exactly is the
story there i i can't tell you what he
received while he was in kuwait um i
know that the the former president has
visited the middle east uh several times
on the behalf of the carlyle group
so let me try to give you an idea of
what exactly he does for the carlyle
group
his job is to
go to foreign governments and and uh
domestic events as well
give speeches sometimes the speeches
have nothing to do with what the carlyle
group actually does as a business
sometimes it's just to comment on world
affairs or other other happenings in the
world
and this is this is meant to first of
all pack the house bring a lot of very
wealthy individuals into the event
and then it's also meant to open up
their wallets and and hopefully have
them invest in the carlyle group so that
the carlyle group can can create larger
funds
now the carlisle group has told me uh
several times that
that is the extent of george bush
senior's role with the company
but there is uh there's a lot of
evidence that says otherwise that he has
actually met with business leaders um
worked deals on behalf of carlyle group
done much more in other words than just
give speeches about unrelated topics so
he has visited saudi arabia he's also
visited kuwait
on behalf of the company other carlisle
group
participants david rubenstein who was
with the carter administration he's a
co-founder also bill canard who is the
fcc chairman under bill clinton arthur
levitt who is the fcsec chairman under
bill clinton newton massachusetts you're
on the air with dan brady go ahead
please hello could you please put this
into perspective for us
how many other companies out there like
the carlyle group
also hire
former politicians to do this kind of
lobbying and consulting for them colin
let me ask you a question before we go
to that what do you think of the idea of
politicians former politicians doing
this kind of work no matter where it is
uh i tend to think that uh it's up to
each individual person to bring their
own ethics to the table and that all of
this sort of thing is uh very acceptable
if it's all done within the law and
within each person's ethical
uh makeup mr brady yeah i think that's a
very healthy view actually um
i think that
the carlyle group is serving as a bit of
a model
for
future
companies
because they've had incredible amount of
success they averaged something on the
uh lines of 35 to 40 return on a lot of
their investments which is uh which is a
lot of money um so i i think that you
see you have we have seen this in the
past
we have certainly are have become very
familiar with halliburton
and the way that that company does
business
it is an american tradition to get close
with
politicians and it is no secret that
that helps your business tremendously
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing illegal with that um it's like
the caller said i i think that you have
to have your own ethical compass and you
have to sort of uh go by that
where is it located physically
right down the street pennsylvania
avenue how many people work there
uh somewhere around 400 people work
there now who runs it today david
rubinstein is still always has been and
is still the the beating heart of the
company chairman of the board today
chairman of the board is lou gerstner
former ibm chairman toronto canada
you're on with dan brady go ahead please
hi i love c-span i watch you guys all
the time up here especially since the uh
the war thing started
my question is uh how old is the carlow
group
did george bush seniors stay at bin
laden seniors when he was in visiting
saudi arabia and are you afraid for your
life sir
maybe waking up with a suicide one
morning unexplained
uh no i'm not afraid for my life the the
company is 15 years old it was founded
in 1987 in late 1987.
um
the bush uh bush and john major uh tend
to tend to stay with the royal family in
saudi arabia when when they when they
visit
the kingdom um and just just to address
your uh concerns from my life first of
all thank you but uh this is not this is
not the trilateral commission this is
not the skull and bones this is this is
nothing along those lines this is the
story of a fascinating american company
that has tied itself very closely to an
administration and has reaped a lot of
financial rewards because of that they
are a very reasonable company
and i don't think my life was ever in
danger you go to the back and look at
the source notes there are two people
that pop up more than anybody else phil
o'dean and stephen norris as your
sources
who are those two men and why were they
the ones that you quoted the most well
steve norris is a co-founder of the
company he founded it along with david
rubenstein back in 1987
and steve left the company
under questionable terms in 1995
he was actually
forced out of the company
due to what some of the partners thought
was erratic behavior on his part now
steve is a very successful businessman
he's done a lot of great deals he worked
some of the biggest deals for carlyle
group during the early going
he worked to deal with the the prince of
saudi arabia prince awa lead
he did a deal with euro disney very
huge uh 590 million dollar deals um that
kind of prince amoled is the biggest
stockholder in the city group that's
right he actually saved the city group
the city group was in serious danger of
going bankrupt back in the early 90s and
steve norris brokered a deal between the
prince and citigroup to invest 590
million dollars in the company and it
really uh picked them up westchester new
york you're on with dan bryant go ahead
please hi there dan hi uh
looks fascinating definitely going to
rush out and buy the book i'm curious
about like the government and
corporation co-mingling in most other
countries when it when a corporation
goes into another country it pays for
its own security essentially if
halliburton and schlumberger have been
given contracts already
shouldn't shouldn't they pay the
american people back i mean that's use
of of the us military as basically an
offense
and i'm curious as to the rush to
baghdad do you think that possibly that
would that could be to possibly to
destroy
the recordings of
saddam and abramsfeld
uh i i can't comment on that but i i do
think that um that the way that the
amer the way that american business is
structured is such that uh
that politics and business do naturally
gravitate towards each other
i think that what's different about the
carlyle group is the amount of work that
they do in defense
and so leading up to the war in iraq it
became
it became a serious conflict of interest
and something that really needed to be
looked very closely at you know the same
situation with halliburton when you're
looking at the rebuilding of iraq
you have to question the ties that
halliburton has to vice president dick
cheney
and as it has come out apparently uh
dick cheney is still receiving a
paycheck from halliburton though he he
is not uh he is not he does not have an
equity stake in the company so he has no
uh stake in whether the company is
financially solving former omb director
dick darmian is he still a member of the
carlisle group he is
colin powell you say had some
association with him in the past where
yeah it's it's unclear uh exactly what
colin powell was doing with the group um
but sometime between
uh the first bush administration the
second bush administration he was
consulting with them advising with them
on an informal basis and what about uh
you have you have michael eisner on your
list but you have george soros who is
not known as a conservative giving lots
of money to this effort over the years
now you have lots of folks who are not
conservative uh working with the group
you've got you know george soros is a is
a very large investor in the company i
think you put 100 million dollars in to
one of their funds um you also have
arthur levitt a former sec chairman
you've got william canard who is the
former fcc chairman
so the company is diversified
politically although it is considered uh
considered to be more of a republican
dan brady forest hill maryland you're on
hello you're on the air go ahead please
how you doing good
um
a couple callers ago somebody expressed
um concern for the authors
i guess life was the
implication and the author thanked him
for that
and i would i would just suggest if if
you were concerned about anybody harming
you that would only happen if you took
on the clintons they're the ones that
had the trail of dead bodies from
arkansas on through their presidency
such as
ins foster jim mcdougall ron brand blah
blah caller let me ask you a question
does any of this concern you that you're
hearing
anything that he's saying yeah no
because i think you have exactly the
same thing on the uh if you want to say
liberal side and he
that would be a good question for him
what are all those former
uh democratic people doing if he would
have any idea because i would
think that whatever they were doing
would you know not be to benefit america
very much however halliburton i was
interested when he brought that up
the you only had three people in
competition
for the job halliburton a canadian
company and a french company so it's
like hello who do you think we're going
to give it to thanks mr brady well uh
there are a couple questions in there
but i i think the the democrats are are
wise to this uh this way of doing
business this uh so-called revolving
door um certainly al gore landed a plum
position with uh metropolitan west after
uh after his failed campaign um of
course he didn't have the same name
cachet as george bush senior but uh but
nonetheless uh it's both the politicians
and the and the business community that
are realizing the value of these of
these marquee names um in terms of doing
their business and very few of these
guys have the sort of business
experience that they really would need
in some of these positions to succeed
does the carlyle group own anything oh
yeah right and do they run it yes uh the
carlyle group is
essentially a holding company so what
they do is
they buy in some cases they buy portions
of company they'll buy an equity stake
some cases they'll buy stock in a
company but in many cases they'll buy a
company outright
and i think the best example of that is
a company called united defense
which is the maker
of the bradley fighting vehicles and the
paladin gun system that we've seen a lot
on tv recently
during the conflict in iraq and
united defense was a company that
carlisle has owned for about five or six
years now and they ended up taking
public actually uh in the fall of 2001
just after september 11. for dan bridey
and this is what the book looks like
it's called the iron triangle a fairly
small book by john wiley we go to
phoenix arizona good morning yeah good
morning
this is uh richard martinez from phoenix
yes sir i have a strong suspicion on the
bush administration and the carlisle
group
that they
hired people to put weapons in those
airplanes to hit those twin towers to
create article 5 to attack iraq
but i can't understand why they're doing
this caller do you really think that
yes i do why would they do that
to take control complete control
killing three thousand people
hey
hitler did more than that
i think he's a lot like him well it's
it's it's absurd
obviously but i think that the fact that
companies like this exist allow people
to sort of draw these outrageous
conclusions and uh and accuse the bush
administration of some uh some obviously
absurd acts um but what i
what what i would tell you is that um
this company is out to make money um
they are they are not out to kill people
um and you're levying some serious
accusations against administration that
has uh has acted pretty admirably um
throughout you say in your introduction
that when you started uh
this whole book you asked carla to talk
to you good day
no they refused to talk to me have you
ever been inside their offices never
been inside the offices never met the
founders except for stephen norris of
course um and that made that made
writing the book very difficult um they
closed off a lot of doors uh for me and
they tell people not to talk to you yeah
they told they told a lot of their
business partners and close friends not
to not to speak to me because they knew
i was researching this book
it makes you a little suspicious of why
they're whether they have something to
hide um but at the same time you know i
can i can understand them not wanting to
have an expose written about their
company fitchburg massachusetts you're
next hi dan yes hi dan uh just curious
about your book
you know we all have our biases you know
i have my opinions of course
i believe clinton was evil and the
bushes are basically uh fairly good
people
do you believe the bushes are evil and
clinton is a good guy no
no i don't believe that i don't believe
that either of them are evil i think
that
it's been it's been a while since i've
seen a president in office that i felt
was truly honest
but i don't believe that either of them
are evil
i believe in
the power of journalism and i believe in
writing stories that are of interest to
people and that reveal facts that people
need to know particularly when it comes
to forming an opinion about a conflict
like iraq you want to have all the facts
your disposal and i think this book
provides some more facts to sort of add
into that mix caller does any of this uh
concern you if no matter what side it's
on either republican or democrat uh no
you know it is the way it is and i kind
of you know
it's just that i think that dan would be
would be happier if clinton was in
office during iraq whereas i would be
i'm thrilled that bush was there not al
gore that's the thing thanks
are you uh political yourself
uh i i try to stay apolitical but i i
tend to find myself drifting towards
left more often than not certainly
during uh the the iraqi conflict i was
feeling that the case had not been made
um sufficiently uh to convince me or the
international community um that we
needed to invade now and i would like to
ask our audience this is not a show
about the iraqi war it is a program
about this book and about the carlyle
group that many of you have called over
the years and so if you can try to keep
your questions on that subject we go to
roy utah good morning
yes this is uh roy utah and i have
a question partly for the last caller
and partly
for him because i find it interesting
the last call or the last your last
guest
said that you should do your own
investigating if you get closed doors
and my interest is
because of all the
issues between
uh the democrats or especially bill
clinton and
the bushes and how they go on this moral
tone
and
i i just don't feel like that
president bush
this one has been investigated the way
that president clinton was and i find it
hard you can't find any information you
hear rumors and stuff like the fact that
he was awol for 18 months steering we're
not going to talk about that this day
please we have very limited amount of
time let's try to stay on the carlyle
group if possible and let me go to a
question about the carlyle group um what
was your reaction when this book was
published did you get any feedback
from the company itself yep
the company has been mum and they've
made a few public statements i'm not
sure if you've been following the news
there have been some
demonstrations outside the carlisle
offices in san francisco and in new york
folks who were demonstrating against war
profiteering and felt that the
carlisle's connections to the bush
family were too tight and that the
military connection um you know the
so-called iron triangle uh was a little
too strong
david rubenstein had a big article in
the washington post he did he had an
excellent excellent expose so they've
turned up the spin machine a little bit
um they they realize uh they're very
aware of their reputation and they're
very aware uh of the fact that no matter
no matter what they tell people people
are always going to have suspicions
about them what's the story of the bin
laden family connection uh you imply in
here that they had a big investment in
the carlisle group it wasn't big as i
remember though was it well these guys
have done business together for years
what ended up happening was after
september 11th some news reports came
out that
the bin laden family had a two million
dollar investment in a carlyle fund that
fund was called carlyle partners two and
it was one of their defense funds so the
awful irony of that whole situation was
that the bin laden family stood to gain
financially on the war that the united
states was waging against their son
essentially
so the heat started getting turned up
around that and uh the carlyle group
eventually severed ties with the bin
laden family how soon after september
the 11th oh i want to say two months uh
but
the
folks that i talked to um have told me
that uh that there was much more
business that had been done between the
saudi bin laden group which is the bin
laden's construction company in saudi
arabia and the carlisle group in
previous years it may have been that
there was only two million dollars
invested at that time
but before that they had done a
significant amount of business with the
with the family debary florida you're on
the air
very florida please go ahead you're on
the air
yes
um i'd like to know what
is the most surprising or shocking
secret that dan uncovered for himself
personally and two will he be exposing
any other secret worlds
uh for us and i'll hang up before you go
collard what do you think you're a
supporter of the president does this
kind of stuff bother you at all
uh no i kind of take it i think that um
and this might be naive on my part but i
just think the president takes
information from a variety of sources
and
and makes um
a decision based on that does it matter
to you that former officials like frank
carlucci and james baker and arthur
levitt and bill connard and all these
people go into business and use their
contacts in order to further their
economic status
um
no
i mean presidents when they
do that when they're finished and they
make speeches and further their economic
status that way
i i'm glad that the president is
surrounded by people with experience
that's the one thing that i do like
i think that he's surrounded himself
with
people who have been through this before
and i think that helps because he hasn't
so mr bradley well uh there's a couple
things there so first uh there were a
number of surprising revelations that
came out during
during the book and i don't want to give
too much of the book away but
suffice to say that the company has ties
to cia cover-up companies that have been
doing business in saudi arabia
under the auspices of training
saudi arabian troops
there have also been some clandestine
arms deals between the united states
between carlyle companies and and russia
after the cold war ended
things like that really really tend to
set you on edge when you're researching
a book like this as for other companies
i very much would like to take a look at
halliburton and
get into
their history that's a fascinating
company with a long long history a great
american company
who has done business
alongside of politicians including lbj
and of course dick cheney and other
folks for years and years so
that's probably my next project what
about somebody on the left side of the
fence that is out there doing the same
thing in a different way maybe not
forming a company but taking large
speaking fees and picking up the
telephone and calling people and getting
involved in the process well i'm open to
anything so any any company that comes
my way i'll uh i'll investigate them i
believe strongly in investigative
journalism and and i think it's it's
this this is this is a subject that is
uh that is bipartisan cleveland you're
on the air dan thank you for making that
statement uh what i find baffling
as a political researcher myself when
you do an expose such as you've done
yourself do you find it troubling that
other
so-called
articles appear to negate what you're
trying to do with what i'm talking about
it's very frustrating
that there is so much information out
there it leaves what i have everybody in
what i call the land of bill wilderman
they don't know what to believe
and it's brilliant in what they do it
really really is because i've done a lot
of research on this you're on the money
there's a book out there also called
forbidden truth the ties to bin laden
which is almost banned in america
how do you overcome that that that
equation that that the way they divide
us well i think you i think you bring up
a great point i mean in some respects
this is this is a game um you you put
out some information they put out some
information um and uh in many times many
times that that information negates
itself so i i think that you can't let
it uh you have to keep plugging away you
can't let it get you down you have to
continue to write what you have
discovered what you've learned as long
as you believe that it's factual and
accurate you have to put it out there
otherwise you've already lost
i understand that there's a website
called the carlislegroup.com
slice
people.htm and it's on our screen there
but it also lists the managing directors
and there are a ton of them um plus uh
their bios have you been on to that
website oh sure many times and what is
there any value to that from what you
know yeah i mean it gives you an idea of
how this company operates i mean it's
it's
the way that they want to uh present
themselves to the world is that we have
very strong political connections and if
you do business with us you will benefit
from those connections so they so at the
same time that they want to sort of keep
these things quiet because it can bring
them some bad publicity they also want
people to know uh that they want their
potential investors to know
we've got a lot of heavy hitters on our
team our guest is dan brady he'll be
with us for another 23 45 minutes we're
going to depu new york here on the air
uh good morning gentlemen hi stan uh i
just happen to not be quite a cynical
let me ask you something if i could just
get a real realistic response
when you started to write this book were
you
looking to find a lot a whole lot more
sinister things than you actually came
up with because let me just make my
point these are private citizens these
are old politicians
and i'm not i'm not looking at any
sinister
doings with a bunch of old politicians
getting together and say hey listen we
all have a certain commonality of
purpose i think we should go and just
try to advance these things and these
people you know one thing i do see that
they believe in and god love them is
they believe in the united states being
a very strong military we see what the
military has done in the recent
prosecution of the war in afghanistan
and in iraq and i've really got no
problem with it and as far as you
finding out information let me tell you
something this is a private organization
you don't you don't have to find out
information i mean you can scour the
hedges and everything but just answer
one question were you expecting to find
a little bit more suspicious behavior
out of this group than you did
carl stay where you are because i want
to come back to you after he answers it
please uh i actually expected to find
exactly what i did find which was uh the
story of a truly fascinating company
that has tied themselves very close with
an administration now what i would what
i would ask you is
i i fully agree and as i said earlier in
the program i fully agree with the
ability for
public servants after they leave office
to matriculate back into the citizenry
and capitalize on the the things that
they have learned that is an american
right i fully support that however it
does not sit well with me that george
bersinia works for a company as one of
the largest defense contractors in this
nation
while his son is pushing a war in iraq
that does not sit well with me
sir i i really see that's where you get
that's where you start to get into all
these conspiracy theories what came
first did george bush all of a sudden
work for a defense contractor because he
says oh goody my son is in the white
house and i also want to make over one
other point he's doing a little thing on
halliburton i'd like to really point out
a couple things one thing specifically
about halliburton
dick cheney this came up way early on in
the bush administration and guess what
happened all the liberals and the
leftists say oh halliburton you know
you're going to get oil in this big oil
dick cheney sold his interest in
halliburton and if people know what the
stock market was doing back when this
was actually going on it was a whole lot
higher than it was right now so what
happened by wrote is that the liberals
forced dick cheney to make a bigger
profit on his investment because they
forced him to sell thanks caller
well dick cheney had to sell his stock
in halliburton that wasn't that wasn't
the liberals making him sell his stock
in in halliburton uh that was a that was
a legal issue
dick cheney made 30 million dollars from
halliburton and um he also did business
with uh iraq while he was with
halliburton um in between stinson's uh
secretary of defense and uh and vice
president
so uh you know
i'm not going to defend or attack dick
cheney but i do think that the
halliburton story
definitely merits some more
investigation
july 2001 you have in your book in the
timeline former president george herbert
walker bush personally calls crown
prince abdullah
of saudi arabia reassuring the heir to
saudi arabia that his son quote
is going to do the right thing unquote
and his heart is in the right place the
call is in response to george w bush
upsetting the saudi prince with his
policy toward the israeli-palestinian
conflict conflict it also helps protect
carlisle's extensive business in the
region now how do you know that he said
that to the to the well that actually
that actually comes from a new york
times report how do you know that they
know what he said well i mean it depends
on how much you trust the new york times
i happen to trust the newspaper pretty
uh pretty much but but the people out
there watching who are on the
president's side often do not trust the
new york times because of their strong
you know they were strongly against this
war so why would you trust them i mean
that that kind of a quote well it's
everything is sourced in the book so
that that piece of information is
sourced in in the book to the new york
times i'm not saying that that was an
original piece of reporting on my part
i'm saying that this was a report that
was that was handed down by the new york
times but let me just just press that
for a moment sure did you know it was in
the new york times was it sourced
directly to this former president or was
it to somebody who overheard the
conversation reporting today it was
someone that overheard the conversation
so you really don't know for sure that
the president ever said that that's true
yes does that kind of thing disturb you
in this mix
disturb me in that that i don't have the
solid evidence
well uh it does i mean i wish i could
have been in that room um while that
conversation took place um i don't find
it hard to believe um though given the
relationship that george bersiner has
had with the with the royal family in
saudi arabia and the early problems that
his son had um with the kingdom uh
during his in his administration so um
yes i do do i wish i could have been in
on every conversation that took place in
the house absolutely with a tape
recorder but
but since i can't i have to rely on on
some of the the good journalists that do
their work norwich new york you on the
air hi
i i
as in regard to your earlier comments
don't you think it's a little
questionable for a former president of
the united states to chase a buck and
chase business in this way while his son
is in the white house
seems to me i can't think of any other
president that's done anything
approaching this they may go out and
make speeches and and get paid you know
for doing so honorariums but this is a
deep involvement in business it kind of
the former president advised his
children first make your money and then
go into government apparently what he
didn't say is when you get out of
government then come go and make some
more money caller is there any
difference in uh say former president
clinton uh making lots of money off of
speeches and and then having a wife who
is in the united states senate is there
any difference between these two stories
people want to listen to the guy's
speeches for whatever reason it's
strictly on his own magnetism he's not
part of a business combine
i don't know of any other president in
my lifetime or even reading in history
that's so deeply immersed in making a
buck
with business contacts
based on his former role as president
and his son's current role as president
dan brady well uh this this is a very
good point and i want to address what
you just said as well brian and that is
that the difference here and this is a
first um having a having a former
president uh working on behalf of a
defense contractor while his son is
waging a war um
that that is definitely a first and that
is something that's uh disconcerting
it's it's what we call a conflict of
interest
and there's a reason that we we uh point
out these conflicts of interest in our
political system because conflicts of
interest can lead to corruption can lead
potentially to corruption um are there
any examples in this mix where maybe
the carlyle group didn't get what it
wants from the government oh yeah there
have been there have been situations
where carlisle has uh had programs shut
down um you know so that they're not
they're not just running rampant over
policy and legislative decisions in this
town
they have their struggles too they're a
business and they need to and they need
to play by the same rules as everyone
else
the the question that i think that needs
to be brought up is why does george bush
senior feel the need to continue working
for this company um even now while
while i believe it undermines the
credibility of his son to some extent uh
while his son is is waging a very
difficult political international
political battle do you have the answer
i don't have the answer should you try
absolutely tried to contact the former
president and uh he declined to comment
so i would love to pose that question to
him and if you're listening
how hard is it to track how many times
he goes out and makes a speech on behalf
of the carlos group
well it's it's not that hard to track
because you you see these things pop up
in the news quite often um when he makes
a speech but oftentimes it doesn't
appear in the news um either and and
it's impossible to track uh when he's
doing business meetings and and that
sort of thing when you talk to steven
norris who was one of the co-founders
where is he by the way today he's based
here in washington d.c did you ask him
the question on whether or not they hire
these ex-politicians for the purpose of
doing exactly what you're concerned
about yeah and and what steve will tell
you is that you know you bring these
guys into the fold uh because of the
contacts that they bring with them um
and because of the doors that they're
able to open you know
if you want to take it the step further
and say that these guys are actually
able to influence legislation that's
being passed with current administration
that's something that i did not want to
get into and it's something that
frankly is almost impossible to prove
when you've got a guy like frank
carlucci who is best friends with donald
rumsfeld they went to princeton to go
their roommates
at princeton university you know these
guys have a social relationship
don rumsfeld is obviously aware that
frank carlucci works for the carlyle
group
when they talk when they go out and have
a drink or or whatever uh is anyone
going to know what they what's passed
between them no it's this type of
influence peddling is impossible to
measure alexandria virginia good morning
good morning thank you for see
mr bridey
i happen to work on the hill for a
number of years almost 20 years and out
in the lobbying group as well and quite
frankly everything in washington think
tanks union groups business groups
the washington law firms are all equal
opportunity and all of them hire these
people for their influence i am curious
that with the carlyle group having been
in business since 1987 over the entire
duration of the clinton administration
and they obviously have influence
peddlers from that group as well why you
didn't uh cover any of that or why you
seem to be emphasizing just the
administration's uh influence with bush
why do you think uh caller
well
i you know i hate conspiracy theories
and so forth i think quite frankly i i
think uh people such as mr bridey do do
a service i do believe in the freedom of
the press and that it does keep
an eye on business and government and
and all sorts of things it's necessary
to the public but i am curious
why these people when they go out that
they emphasize one versus another
instead of trying to get more of an even
tone throughout let me ask you this
question when you were in either the
lobbying firm or up on capitol hill did
you ever feel uneasy about this
connection between the old time leaders
and the current government um in some
instances but for the most part no
because quite frankly uh the members of
congress and all are being bombarded by
both sides and quite frankly i think
most of our government and most business
as well
um does have some personal integrity i
don't believe they're all scoundrels and
scum
and i believe most of them make an
effort to walk the balance
and take advice from both sides to try
to come to good agreements there are
times when
there are corrupt men and women in all
facets of
so it's not just
a matter of the bush administration
versus the clinton administration i i
believe for the most part these are men
and women
who do try
obviously
what is the rule of thumb in in every
population of any sort they're always 10
10 who are going to taint the barrel of
apples all right thank you mr bridey
well i uh if you read the book you'll
see that it chronicles the history of
the company throughout the clinton years
from 87 all the way through to present
day so
i don't think i skimped on the clinton
years at all um it just so happens that
uh this company has extensive ties to
the current administration which i think
makes them uh compelling at this point
in time particularly with uh with the
conflict in iraq and and uh and the war
on terrorism and that's why uh we've
been focusing on that today um and the
latter half of the book focuses on that
gainesville florida you're on the air
yes good morning gentlemen hi uh sir uh
the writer uh i would like to ask you a
hypothetical perhaps let's say uh the
carlyle group offered you
5 million a year gave you a 10-year
contract to write exposes or
investigative journaling journalism for
them
and possibly to investigate
senator clinton's cattle futures terry
mccauley's
gigantic
move in the stock market
would you be willing to do that well i
don't think i'd be willing to
take the corporate hand out hopefully my
ethics would uh would hold strong it
would be tough to turn down 5 million
dollars though
but like i said earlier in the program i
will investigate
republicans
democrats
with equal zeal
let's go to new york city good morning
uh good morning
i'd like to ask mr briote
in his research did he come across
the carlisle group's investment in sayak
which is the easy pass company
uh who stephen hatfield also worked for
another question is he aware of the
communication center on atlantic avenue
in brooklyn that they own which is
rather large that carries many many
transactions from wall street
ju is he aware of
the carlyle group's attempt to buy la
figaro in the french press why are you
aware of all this car
well because i've done some research on
my own why
um
very interested in the activities of the
carlisle group
is that all you're gonna tell us uh no
the only uh that's all i'm going to tell
you but the other question i have is he
aware or does he remember the picture in
the new york times on 9 10 01
the day before 9 11 01
uh where the carlisle group opened the
new york stock exchange
all of these things
have been have been looked at and
the company owns
somewhere along the lines of 300
different companies so
you're talking about les figaro they
actually do own
they also have recently bought
kinetech which is the
defense research arm of the
the uk's ministry of defense and they
just recently completed a deal
to buy the state controlled defense and
aerospace arm of fiat
in italy um so these guys uh their their
net is cast far and wide they own
everything from dr pepper bottling
companies to health care firms to
defense agencies to stock uh tracking
companies to
um you know the list goes on and on and
you know if if your suspicions run very
deep then you then you believe that
these guys are sort of uh their
tentacles are spreading throughout the
world but they're certainly not the only
company that uh that is in this kind of
diversified business internationally now
will they the kind of company that will
be watching this program this morning to
keep an eye on you i can't say if
they're fans of your program well it's
not of course i'm fans of this program
but are they following you wherever you
go and i don't know uh they i i was in
communication with them during the
writing of the book i was talking with
their corporate communications
department
um sporadically uh but they declined to
comment on all the questions that i had
um and then after the book came out uh
they sort of went silent and how much of
what they do is public
uh very little it the the stuff that is
public is the stuff that has to do with
public companies so when they're
investing in a public company that
information has to be disclosed by sec
standards
but they are a private company so they
are not under obligation to reveal any
of their financial information
and they invest in many private firms
hence the name private equity do you
have any idea who's made the most money
over the last how many years now 15
years which which company in there no
individual that's been associated with
carl arbor no i but i would have to
guess it would be david broomstein he's
the one that has been with them since
the beginning and uh he he as a partner
he takes a cut of uh of all the deals
that they do and he comes out of the
carter administration comes out of the
car administration new york city you're
on go ahead please good morning brian uh
great show
three quick points one uh it's a
question is there a crossover between
say i think the carlisle based on
carlisle hotel the bilderbergers and are
the same people players in many of these
uh
like organizations like i don't know the
trilateral number two
if you would follow uh your story like
maybe you could do this before your
paperback comes out
and had done like say a documentary
following the facts and making sort of a
uh you know covering the same material
you're doing the book was a great job
really fantastic
i think that it would make uh would make
you a higher profile target of course
but at the same time you'd reach more
people because there's so much dumbed
down stuff that here you are on c-span
but take it a step further next time
third thing
uh i think that brian has a show with
you know for uh they promoted earlier
about
leaders and students it's sort of a i
guess college and high school
anyway if you had a god gave a speech
say at one of these uh
graduation ceremonies and you get a
chance to do that you might want to
promote the idea that
the role model of uh networking like for
instance that you bring out in your book
between all these guys who are in
government then went on to make more
money maybe you could promote this at
the graduation that people should really
start networking within their own groups
really big time and that's how to do it
thanks
well uh let's see i mean it's just an
object lesson that people ought to
follow instead of not follow i i do
agree that uh that it deserves follow-up
and that um i will continue to you know
appear publicly
and talk about this kind of these kind
of business arrangements
not just about the carlyle group but
about all companies that do this i do
believe that we need more uh regulation
of this this type of behavior because i
think it's getting a little too accepted
in our in our culture and answer your
first question the company is actually
named after the carlisle hotel in new
york city where the founders
frequented early in the during the
formation of the company
ithaca new york good morning
uh and first thank you very much for
c-span
uh
i am interested in the title the iron
triangle because there is this is
something that i have been very
concerned about
and
my conception of an iron triangle
something that makes me very pessimistic
about the future of democracy in our
country
and i think that there is this
connection between corporate interests
government and the media and especially
as the media becomes more and more
concentrated and owned by fewer and
fewer
very wealthy individuals and large
groups
so that it's very difficult for the
interests of the people to actually get
a hearing in congress
and uh
for even for the people to be well
informed about what's going on because
to me this really is an iron triangle
government big business and media
well that's that's a slightly different
definition of the iron triangle than
than the one that we're employing with
the book um the iron triangle that we
refer to in the book is business
politics and the military um that was a
euphemism that dwight eisenhower
employed before he left off as the
president about 40 years ago now
eisenhower warned against the formation
of a military-industrial complex this
sort of behemoth that could
that was based on the military business
that could influence politicians towards
war
that was what eisenhower was warning
against the iron triangle has a lot of
definitions obviously the iron triangle
of george bush uh and and karen hughes
um and joe alba are
that's that's another iron triangle so
it's it's a well-worn euphemism but in
this case we are referring to uh
politics business in the military as
books go 159 pages of the actual meat of
the book is short it's a brisk read it's
a brisk read but the company's only been
around for 15 years and uh and we
certainly had some time constraints in
getting the book out but but i think
you'll find more than enough information
in the book
to satisfy your needs 24.95 if you buy
at retail in the stores lansing michigan
go ahead please yes i'm not being
facetious when i'm asking this young
author would he think that someone just
out in the
hinterlands going in and doing what he's
saying like contacting the king over
here and so on and so forth would that
be wisdom or should we have the
experience of these politicians and what
they're doing and it and hopefully it's
for the value of the whole world
well i for one am glad that uh george
foresenior is advising his son on
foreign policy um certainly
george w bush didn't have a lot of
experience in foreign policy when he
took office so i have no problem with
that the problem that i have is that he
has financial investments in many of the
countries that he is advising his son on
so that's what makes me a little
uncomfortable i'd be much more
comfortable if george foresenior would
resign his position with the carlyle
group and go on to make money some other
way there's certainly no no limit to the
opportunities that the man has right now
but but as for advising
his son in office i'm all for it what
does john major do running carlyle group
europe uh he does much of the same thing
that david rubenstein does here in the
in the united states
john major is a contact uh he obviously
has has a number of contacts and a lot
of influence in the uk and it's just
starting to get the european business
and the carlyle group up and running new
york city you're on please go ahead yes
uh good morning uh i want to ask you a
question or concerning
the relationship between carl bush and
global crossing it's my understanding
that mr bush made a speech at the global
crossing meeting received a lot of stock
for free
sold that stock and made millions of
dollars profit before
global crossing went under and went
bankrupt and now it's my understanding
that call out group is buying some of
the assets
that uh global crossing had
to me that's a little
fishy uh well i think that's that's a
little bit of a red herring to use your
uh your fishy comment um i think what
happened with global crossing is and
this is not unusual for the former
president to do this uh to give a speech
in return for stock options in a company
or equity in a company that's a
perfectly suitable arrangement
it's just the same as receiving a
straight cash fee
now that happened well before global
crossing went under and the carlisle
group is heavy into telecommunications
and they decided that it was an
opportunity to buy some of their assets
and are in negotiation right now for
some of the assets of global crossing
but i don't think the two events have
anything to do with each other do you
have any idea how much time george
herbert walker bush spends with the
carlob group
no it's not clear how much time uh he's
spending although i get the impression
from folks uh who were with the company
that he really enjoys the day-to-day
interaction with these guys and he
really enjoys being engaged in
international business and is quite good
at it let's go for our last call to
pittsburgh pennsylvania for dan briatti
go ahead please yes good morning good
morning morning mr bratty um just a um
quick question why why would a company
oppose an expose if it has nothing to
hide and i have a suggestion for your
next expose
check out us airways there's been a lot
of shenanigans going on with this
company for the last 20 years management
wise
thank you
well that's uh that that's a question um
that you'd have to ask the carlyle group
um they certainly didn't want to answer
it for me uh but uh i i think a lot of
companies fear this kind of publicity um
it's a company that tries to stay low um
because they do have they do have so
many ex-politicians and are open to
criticism so i don't i'm not surprised
that they didn't want to talk openly
about uh about their business and they
do do it sometimes too uh to specific
reporters occasionally they will talk
and u.s airways we'll give it a look
what did you do before you wrote this
book
i was writer for red herring magazine
which is a technology and business
magazine which is now defunct like so
many other technology and business
magazines so what are you going to do
next well i'm freelancing right now and
i am looking into my next book which is
about halliburton
and when do you expect to have it out
hopefully in a year's time but but i
want to give it enough time that i can
really give it a thorough treatment and
this the correct i think i had an extra
syllable it's just
variety variety right yes yes you find
people have trouble with it all the time
all the time uh where did you get the
title the iron triangle uh like i said
the iron triangle is uh a euphemism that
i didn't mean that so much is when did
you decide that this was going to be the
right title for that oh actually i wrote
an article for red herring about the
carlyle group back in 2001 in the fall
of 2001 and uh that that article was
entitled the iron triangle as well i
want to go back over though we started
to talk about that you found nothing
illegal that this group was doing is
that correct that's correct did you
expect to find anything illegal uh i
can't say i mean i i think that uh
there was certainly the possibility when
i embarked on this that that something
like that would would come up but uh it
really i really wasn't in a hunt to find
illegal activity i was in this in this
to tell the story of a company that is
closely tied to an administration and
and look at how that is done and why
it's done
this is what the book looks like it's
called the iron triangle inside the
secret world of the carlyle group and we
want to remind our viewers that um
on sunday night we have our second part
of our two-part series on book notes
with william taubman on the khrushchev
biography that's at 8 o'clock and 11
o'clock east coast time and next week as
meg steele just told us we start our
students and leaders
program which will
go throughout the entire month of may
and the students and leaders are 40 high
schools in this area and we'll have uh
actually uh 40 high schools and 40
guests over 20 days and you'll have a
chance to see it all on the
c-span 3 or on the c-span 2 or 1
networks later on that's it for this
friday we go now to china for their
evening newscast
you are watching cctv international